I got a call from Rick Farman and
Jonathan Mayer's who both New York guys
and I'm in New York and they came up
they're like we they caught they reach
out to me and they're like hey we work
with Galactic now and you work with the
All Stars and we'd like to talk to you
about during their press we're gonna be
in New York next week let's have lunch
so this is in 2001 I said yeah great so
we met at a restaurant called communion
on Broadway in 22nd Street and we were
having a great lunch at the very end of
the lunch it was really a fun lunch we
had we were really clearly clicking it
was just you know that we're all like no
no we all get along it's great we still
did right but at the end of the lunch
they go hey so just throwing it out
there we're thinking of starting this
summer festival we don't know what it's
called yet we don't know where it's
gonna be held but you seem pretty cool
like would you maybe want to work with
us on it and I'm like I've never done an
event before I've never worked on any
event PR before and they said well we've
never thrown an event before and I'm
like well cool let's do it together
they're like done so and in my I have a
file on my computer it's called
proposals where I keep all my proposals
and I do it by year and in 2001 there's
still a proposal in my computer that
says summer festival Wow
it's the 2001 part that's blowing my
mind yeah so y'all put this together in
a year they had already been working on
it I know PR is usually the last part of
the puzzle okay it's kind of like the
health permit
the jury to the stories that define the
artists claim who are they what are they
what will you see the what which bands
this year that matter day brats diners
and barre chords